now it looks like it looks like we could
be moving closer to a brexit deal from
what you've heard and I appreciate its
just reports is there something the SMP
could potentially back if it was then
put to a confirmatory referendum well
we've made it very clear that there's no
such thing is he good brexit Scotland
voted to remain in the European Union 62
to 38% and we've no desire to see
ourselves dragged out against her wishes
leaving the European Union is going to
be damaging for jobs it's going to
damage our communities that are economic
experts has said there could be a hit of
up to 100,000 jobs in Scotland people
being 2,300 pounds a year worse off this
is not a price that's worth paying for
what is Tory ideology we need to stay in
the European Union which is certainly be
staying in the single market and the
customs union which is the least worst
option for us but let's wait and see
what happens this week we haven't seen a
deal come forward from Boris Johnson the
way that we've been talking about I
think over the course of the next 24-48
hours we'll get more clarity on this but
I'd just express a degree of caution the
people are expecting that we're going to
get a deal before the end of the week
and what I would say to Boris Johnson
and to the Conservatives that they must
respect the been act that Parliament has
taken back control and has legislated to
make sure that we don't leave on an
audio basis at the end of October and
that is the first priority that we face
talking about the Ben Act and that of
course is the at compelling Boris
Johnson according to the Act to seek
this extension if he doesn't get a deal
and if he does not request that
extension my interview with Jeremy
Corbyn made pretty clear that they are
going to be calling a vote of confidence
in the Prime Minister shortly after if
that happens and Boris Johnson losers
would you back Jeremy Corbyn as an
interim prime minister I think it's
really about focusing on what the
priorities are and the priority is to
get that extension letter signed and
once that's done as quickly as possible
to move on to innovation now under our
Constitution we need to have a caretaker
administration I don't think it's
actually so much about who forms our
caretaker administration better
making sure that we work together that
collectively we recognize the
responsibilities that we have and the
SNB for the last few weeks have been
calling for a motion of no confidence
because quite simply Boris Johnson is
not someone that we can trust he hasn't
given any indication any clear
indication any way that he will observe
the bear night the simplest thing for
the opposition to do is recognize our
responsibility by having that motion of
no-confidence and removing this toxic
prime minister from 10 Downing Street by
taking the keys of 10 Downing Street
away from him and let's put those back
to the people let's have a general
election which we and the SNP are
absolutely desperate to see to give the
people of Scotland and indeed the rest
of the United Kingdom their see and what
they want to happen going forward and I
think for us what we've seen is the
chaos and the confusion of Westminster
over the course of the last three and a
half years and we want to talk to the
people of Scotland it should be their
right to choose their future whether or
not they wish to see Scotland as an
independent country in Europe or to
carry on with this brexit Murdoch that
we see in this taking us to the warrens
the cliff edge that Boris Johnson wants
to do we had a European country and we
wish to remain so and what should come
first then an election or a second
referendum well I think in terms of the
way our politics work it's going to take
some time to put up the legislation for
a referendum the first thing to do the
right thing to do is to have that
election let the people have their say
and then we can move forward from there
but I want that opportunity to take
Boris Johnson out of office and I want
the opportunity for the people of
Scotland to see very clearly that we
want to see in our own future Sophie you
may well have been aware that there is
an opinion poll in The Sunday Times this
morning and it demonstrates that 45% to
Scots recognized they'd be better off
with Scotland being independent in
Europe against 35% that see the future
been better staying within the UK it's
becoming increasingly clear to people
here that our economic future the
well-being of our country is going to be
best served by completing that job -
independence that started with
devolution 20 years ago just talking
about and the possibility of a uk-wide
election for now that you clearly want
to see if it happens the polls also
indicate that there's a pretty good
chance there could be a hung parliament
would you be prepared to support a
Jeremy Corbyn administration to try and
get into number 10 if he doesn't have
the numbers without you well first
foremost I think everyone's got to take
their own responsibility is and we'll do
our job and taking on the brexit ears
taking on the conservative and indeed
the Labour Party and the Liberal
Democrats in Scotland that I'm confident
that we will win that election it's up
to the other opposition parties to do
the same we want of course to see the
end to austerity we want to see that
legislation for an independence
referendum because the power to do that
must be in the hands of the Scottish
Parliament not in any Prime Minister in
London and of course in the basis of a
hung parliament we'll make sure that we
do our job standing up for Scotland and
delivering on the agenda that the SNP
will go into this election on pretty
clear there that you would like to see
you know the possibility of a second
independence referendum as part of any
of those talks in my interview with
Jeremy Corbyn he said he wouldn't
consider a second vote on Scottish
independence in the first few years of a
Labour government but do you think he's
open to it I think it has to be added
simply say to Jeremy Corbyn that we have
a mandate for an independence referendum
already that was won in the 2016
election the election to the Scottish
Parliament of the SNP one and there is
an independence majority within that
Parliament's that simply say to Jeremy
and indeed to anybody else that maybe in
10 Downing Street they have to respect
democracy and they have to respect the
right of the people that live in
Scotland to determine their own future
we're putting legislation through the
Scottish Parliament now that will enable
that referendum to take place that
referendum should take place in 2020 now
you're speaking of course from the SNP
conference today and I'm King just to
talk a little bit about the SNP record
on education something that of course
you've said previously is a big priority
for you but according to figures from
the government and three intense got his
children leaving primary school did say
without meeting the literacy targets
last year is that really good enough I
think what you have seen over the course
of the last year used under this SNP
government the education of attainment
has improved the number of people that
are going on to university and been
particular the people that are going to
university from disadvantaged and pure
backgrounds and indeed
those are leaving schools in Glasgow for
example where three hires has increased
demonstrably over the course of the last
few years Nicola Sturgeon has made it
very clear that our priority is causing
the attainment gap and I can tell you
right up and down the country we are
seeing the signs of that as beginning to
happen we have a proud record on
education just as we have a very proud
record on health where we're
outperforming the health services in
other parts of the United Kingdom
particularly when it comes to accident
and emergency of course we want to do
more we want to do better but this is an
SNP government that's delivered for the
people of Scotland over the course of
the last 12 years and a whole range of
policies a government that's mitigated
the worst effects of Tory austerity you
know I find it quite remarkable that
many of the things which should in
jeremy corbyn's manifesto that he
announced at the labor conference or
things that the SNP is already done free
tuition the fact that we've got free
personal care this is a government which
is on side of the people of Scotland
whether it's an education health are a
whole range of other domestic policies
the question they was about whether it's
good enough that 3 and 10 Scottish
children a leaving primary school
without metering literacy targets I mean
this is one of the most basic things
that as a parent you would expect your
child to be coming away with isn't it
well look at the end of the day this is
a clear focus that we that we have and
you picked a 1-1 metric there Sophie but
the fact is across education that
there's been considerable advances that
this government has made over the course
of the last few years and of course were
not complacent when it comes to literacy
and other things then we need to make
sure that we can improve our performance
and that's very much what we're focused
on doing ok thank you very much for
being on the program today and it's
nothing away from your conference for a
short while thank you